JIMMY PEARSON: So
without further ado,
I'll bring up Rob Smith.
[APPLAUSE]
ROB SMITH: Thank you.
JIMMY PEARSON: So I
talk to Rob beforehand
about maybe letting him give
his own biography because I'm
pretty sure I wouldn't be
able to do it any justice.
ROB SMITH: Yeah, so here I am.
Well, first of all, I want to
thank you all for having me.
I really appreciate having the
platform and the opportunity
to talk about my book, but
also talk about all the issues
that we're going to
discuss, that are about it.
So my name is Rob Smith.
I'm, among other
things, the author
of "Confessions of a Don't
Ask, Don't Tell Soldier:
How a Black Gay Man Survived
the Infantry Coming Out
in the War in
Iraq," which is what
we're going to be talking
a lot about today.
I'm also a lot of
different things.
I'm a black man, I'm a
gay man, I'm a veteran.
I'm somebody who--
yeah, yeah, right?
JIMMY PEARSON: Right,
yeah, that's right.
ROB SMITH: And there is not--
and it's really interesting
that I got that
shout out, because I
work in media right now.
So I'm kind of like an
activist turned journalist.
So I'm a journalist at
Yahoo Finance right now.
And there are-- a lot
of these identities
that I inhabit are very
under-represented in media
today and in tech.
So it feels good to get
that shout out as a veteran.
So, yeah, I'm the
author of this book.
I'm a black man.
I'm a gay man.
I'm a veteran.
I'm a lot of different things.
And I won't bore you with
going through the form bio,
but that's all on the website,
robsmith.online.com and find it
on the Twitter bio and all that.
So I hope you guys like
look me up, and follow me,
and all that other stuff.
JIMMY PEARSON: Yeah, and
actually while we're at it,
I should say there are
copies of Rob's book
available in the back for
$10, getting a nod, cool.
So if you are interested,
they're available in the back.
And we will also have time
for questions at the end.
So friendly reminder up front,
and I'll repeat it again,
when you do have a question,
don't just shout it out.
Line up behind the mics so that
we can get it on the recording.
ROB SMITH: And I'll be around
to sign any copies that
are purchased today as well.
JIMMY PEARSON: Cool.
So yesterday was
international coming out day.
And there is a really
interesting excerpt
in your book from when
you came out to your mom.
And I thought given that
international coming out day
was yesterday, that might
be an appropriate place
to start if you want, if
you don't mind reading it.
ROB SMITH: I don't
mind reading at all,
that's while we're here.
Yeah, yesterday
was coming out day.
And did a lot of
tweeting, usually
do talks on coming out day.
To me, coming out
day is about being
represented in all of your
identities everywhere you are.
I don't have to come out as
a black man all the time.
This is the first thing that
people see when they see me.
But I am put in the position
to come out as a gay man,
over, and over, and over
again, and you pick and choose
the different ways that
you want to come out.
Now this excerpt that
I'm going to read right
now is me coming out over
the phone to my mother
when I was very young,
and when I was just
starting out in the military.
It did not go
well, and I'll just
read this little bit for you.
I opened the door
to the barracks room
slowly and discreetly and picked
up the phone to dial my mother.
I wasn't sure why
I felt the need
to do to provide a
teaser to a conversation
that we wouldn't be
having for two months,
but a strong sense of
relief had come over me
ever since I admitted it to
myself, I'm gay, I like guys.
I heard her warm, yet gravelly
voice, on the other end.
She'd obviously been smoking.
"Hello," she said.
"Hey mom, it's me,
how you doing?"
"Fine, and you?"
"I'm OK, what are you up to?"
"Just driving,
Robert, what's up?"
"Uh, nothing."
I felt my throat
begin to close up.
I suddenly became
tense and nervous,
and I was struggling to
find the words to say.
"So why are you
calling me, Robert?
I'm on the road driving."
Husband number three
lived in North Carolina.
He worked for a
truck driving company
that delivered loads
of various products
all across the country.
She'd moved down my
senior year of high school
and embarked on a career
in driving, leaving
me to live with
paternal grandparents
for the remainder of my time.
"Um, OK, you know I'm coming
back home for Christmas,
right?"
"Yes, Robert, I know."
"Well, there's something I
wanted to talk to you about."
There was a long uncomfortable
stream of absolute silence.
I could hear the wind
whipping in the background
from the cracked window
of her 18 wheeler.
I wondered what city she was
driving to this time, what
the scenery was like
wherever she was,
anything to fill the silence.
After what seemed like forever,
she continued, "What is it?
You're not gay, are you?"
The words hit me like a
well-timed punch to the gut.
My knees buckled a little bit.
And I stumbled onto the
corner of my bed, shocked.
"Well, what if I was?"
I said, in a quiet
little boy voice.
"Robert, you know that's not
allowed in the army," she said.
"You also know that's
not God's plan."
Her voice was cold and
harsh, unforgiving.
Whatever the words to
respond to this were,
I couldn't find them.
"Do you hear me?"
She said.
I felt like I was adrift, like
I was floating above myself
watching this happen.
It wasn't supposed
to happen like this.
I was supposed to
call and give her
a primer that I wanted to
talk to her about something,
so that maybe it wouldn't
be such a big shock when
I told her during the holiday.
When I did tell her
after Christmas dinner,
she would hug me and tell
me that she loved me,
and that I was her
son no matter what.
I would hug her
back as tears of joy
streamed down my cheeks,
while flurries of perfectly
soft white snow fell outside.
That was how it was supposed
to happen, but it wasn't.
It was happening right now,
and I wasn't exactly feeling
the love.
"Yes, I hear you," I said,
in a low-defeated croak.
"And you better not tell anybody
else either, you hear me boy?
Those people there
are not to be trusted,
and you can't be
getting kicked out.
How are you going to pay for
college if you get kicked out?
Where you going to live?"
"I don't know, mom."
"I know you don't.
Is that what you
called me about?
I got to get back to driving.
Call me next week."
She hung up, and I sat on the
edge of the bed, motionless.
Soon after, I
realized I was crying.
Out in the distance I could
hear the faint chant of soldiers
calling cadence while they ran.
Their voices comforted me.
When I heard them, it was
almost as if I wasn't so alone.
And it was only when they
stopped that I knew I was.
[APPLAUSE]
JIMMY PEARSON: Thank
you for reading that.
I think, it's actually
kind of funny,
because I feel my own heart
rate rising as I sit here,
hearing you read it, because
I think a lot of-- there's
a lot of similarities between
a lot of coming out experience.
And clearly, I
could see that you
were transported back there
a little bit as you read it.
And I appreciate you
sharing that with us.
One thing I wanted
to ask you about
is the very end of
that passage where
you talk about hearing
the soldier's calling
cadence in the background and
feeling comforted, but then
feeling very, very alone.
And I wanted to ask you, I think
that that points to something
that kind of runs throughout
the book, of the Army
being a source of community
and a source of comfort
in a lot of
circumstances, but also,
in some ways,
because of Don't Ask,
Don't Tell, exacerbating your
loneliness at the same time.
Was it both of those things?
Was it really more one of
those things than the other?
What was that
juxtaposition like for you?
ROB SMITH: You know, I think
it was both of those things.
I think that when I
talk about the military,
and when you read the
book, you'll find out,
a lot of people think that
just writing this book,
that I'm here to
bash the military
or bash being a vet or
anything, because they actually
had that discriminatory
policy for so long.
And that's not what I do.
I think things are more--
there are more shades of gray.
It's not a total
black and white thing.
When I was in the
military, I did
feel completely isolated
from other people, purely
because of my
sexual orientation,
because I knew what it
was, and because I also
knew that I could get kicked out
of the military at any point.
And when I talk about
Don't Ask, Don't Tell,
and when I talk about
serving under that,
I think it's really
important for people
to realize that what happens
when you get kicked out under
Don't Ask, Don't
Tell, is that you
get a dishonorable discharge.
That means college
benefits gone,
health care benefits gone.
All of these things that have
made my life so much better
as a veteran, who did get
an honorable discharge,
would get taken away.
And I think that
that really connects
to a lot of the battles
that we're having right
now as an LGBTQ community about
equal workplace protections.
Conversations that we're
having with trans people being
able to be open and out
about their identities
at work right now.
So I felt very alone, very
isolated because of this.
But at the same time, I had
a lot of good relationships
with people that I served with.
I had a lot of good times.
I felt a lot of camaraderie.
I felt a brotherhood.
And I only say brotherhood,
because the infantry was all
male.
So that was a combat
position that wasn't
open to women at the time.
So I really did feel all that.
But at the same time,
having to serve under
Don't Ask, Don't Tell, made
it that much more difficult.
I felt like I couldn't
be my entire self.
We have these conversations
about bringing
our entire selves to the
workplace when we are LGBTQ,
or we are Latino,
or African-American,
or any of these other
different identities.
And I felt like I couldn't
bring my entire identity
to that workplace.
JIMMY PEARSON: Do you think
that that inhibited your ability
as a soldier in any way?
ROB SMITH: Absolutely, because
serving in the military
depends on you bringing
100% of yourself to the job.
I was a good soldier.
I was an OK soldier.
I felt, when looking
back at it, I
feel like if I was
able to be out,
I could have been
a great soldier,
an amazing soldier.
Because I wouldn't have had to
have that barrier that's there,
that had to be there to keep
me from everywhere else.
I feel like right now, in
the position that I'm in,
whether it's reporting
at Yahoo Finance,
whether it's doing
talks, and things
like that, I'm able to bring
my entire self to work.
And even though that may not
be the most comfortable thing
at all times for other people,
it's more comfortable for me,
because I feel like I don't
have anything to hide.
I don't have to hide
the fact that I just
got married a month ago.
I don't have to watch my--
[APPLAUSE]
Thanks.
JIMMY PEARSON: Congratulations.
ROB SMITH: Thank you.
You guys will applaud if
you guys see his cape.
Follow me on Instagram.
His cape was amazing.
But I don't have to pick
and choose my pronouns
when I'm talking about the
person that's in my life,
I can say this is my husband,
and this is what's going on.
And at that point
in time, yes, it
did make me feel completely
separated from everyone else,
because I couldn't be open
about who I really was.
JIMMY PEARSON: This
might get into a question
I was going to ask you after
your next reading, actually.
Are there any ways that
you felt that as a gay man
you could actually
be a better soldier,
or you brought something
more to the table
than maybe your straight
brothers in arms did?
ROB SMITH: You know,
that's so funny,
because I've never gotten
that question before.
And so I really have
to think about it.
And now that I'm thinking
about the question,
I think the only
thing that I can say,
as somebody who is
gay or somebody who
is a person of color,
I think that there's
an empathy that comes in seeing
the world from other people's
eyes.
And when I get into the
chapters about Iraq in the book,
and I have a reading from Iraq
coming up a little bit later,
I think that I was
able to empathize
with the plight of the
people that were there,
maybe more so than some
of the other soldiers who
were straight, white dudes.
And there's nothing wrong with
straight, white dudes, OK?
There's nothing wrong with
straight, white dudes.
It's just that it's more
intrinsic to me as a gay man,
as a black man, to be able to
see the world through the lens
of somebody who is not
like most other people
that I'll come
into contact with.
JIMMY PEARSON:
That's interesting.
ROB SMITH: Do I do
I think being gay
would help me do my job any
more or less than anybody else?
I don't really think so.
JIMMY PEARSON: Yeah.
ROB SMITH: I was a
pretty good shot.
I was a great shot.
JIMMY PEARSON: That
makes one of us.
ROB SMITH: Yeah, better than
a lot of the straight people,
actually--
funny enough.
JIMMY PEARSON: And you
don't think that anything
to do with your
sexual orientation.
ROB SMITH: It could be.
JIMMY PEARSON: You never know.
ROB SMITH: Well now that we
can be out in the military now,
somebody needs to
commission this study.
And we need to see like
gays, and lesbians,
and trans soldiers, we
need to see how they're
shot compare to straight ones.
Maybe it can be an argument
for LGBTQ recruitment.
JIMMY PEARSON: Hey
you know, we'll
take whatever we can get, right?
Actually, what I
was thinking of,
and I think it's related
to your empathy point,
and about putting yourself
in someone's shoes,
is kind of code
switching, and the ability
that a lot of LGBT
folks have to do that.
And I think that's related to
your next excerpt, which it's
a really entertaining
part of the book, where
you talk about your first
experience at a gay club.
ROB SMITH: The first gay club.
JIMMY PEARSON: I think there's
some points in there about code
switching, as well.
So do you mind sharing?
ROB SMITH: Yeah, and this is--
technically, it's
my second gay club.
My first one was in Ohio
when I was 17 years old.
And we won't go throw
that place out there.
I think they're still around.
JIMMY PEARSON: Don't want
to get anyone in trouble?
ROB SMITH: No, no, not at all.
So I found myself
in my barracks room
later that night, once again
in front of the computer,
but this time it
wasn't for online sex.
Sergeant Norman, as creepy and
terrifying as he was to me,
had provided an opportunity that
I had never really been aware
of until now.
I type Hide and Seek
Colorado Springs
into the Google search
bar, and anxiously clicked
on the web site.
After I winced at the choppy
yellow and black flash
animation that opened the site,
I looked at the information.
Hide and seek, as
I was informed,
via the text on the website, was
Colorado Spring's hippest gay
and straight inclusive bar.
It was open on the
weekends until 5:00 am.
It was 21-plus until 2:00
am and 18-plus afterwards.
I cringed at having to wait
until 2:00 am to get in,
but I knew exactly what I was
going to be doing this weekend.
I'd only been to one
other gay club in my life.
It was a small hole
in the wall called
Club X in Sandusky, Ohio.
I'd spent the summer after
high school graduation
working in an amusement
park, and truly exploring
what quote, unquote, gay,
meant for the first time,
at least on the dance floor.
The first time I entered, it
was like sensory overload.
It was the darkest place
I'd ever been to in my life,
lit only by a strobe disco
ball and the lights of the bar.
I looked to my
right and saw boys
dancing with boys and
girls dancing with girls
for the first time in my life.
Their bodies dripped
with sweat and glitter,
sparkling as the glitter
bounced from the strobe lights.
There were many nights that
summer I spent twirling,
being free on the dance floor.
I was twirling before
Kenya Moore, by the way.
A couple people got that.
I thought back to
those nights, as I
made the decision to go to Hide
and Seek, just to check it out.
The night I was to make my
initial trip to the gay bar,
I paced around the small
barracks room in anticipation.
It had been a while since my
nights at the gay bar in Ohio.
I modeled my clothing choices
after the men on Queer
as Folk, which I still watch
religiously every week,
fully absorbing the show's
ideas about gay life.
Oh, God.
I walked into the bathroom and
looked at myself in the mirror.
I wore a black A-shirt,
chosen to show off
the muscles I had gained from
the days spent working out
in Kuwait, and a skin-tight
pair of leather pants
I'd bought from a discount
store a few days earlier.
I don't usually read
the section aloud,
so I'm finding it quite
entertaining, actually.
There were a lot of men in the
club scenes on Queer as Folk
that wore leather
clothes, so I figured
that was the popular look.
As I pranced back and forth
in front of the mirror,
while keeping an eagle
eye on the clock,
I imagined what it would be
like to walk into the gay club.
Would men want me?
Would I be desired?
I thought so, and it
made me even more excited
to make the trip.
I put on a large coat and
walked out of the barracks room
to my car.
I instinctively looked around
to make sure nobody noticed me.
Got in the car and pulled
out as silently as possible.
In my hand, I held directions
that I'd printed out.
And I was surprised to see the
club was only a 15 minute drive
from the base.
When I pulled up to it, I
was struck at how ordinary
it looked.
It was a small building
offset by two outside patios
on both sides.
An ancient awning hung
over the entrance decks.
Several men hung out lazily
on the old patio furniture
that decorated the decks.
I summoned my energy
and exited the car.
The brisk wind stimulating
goose flesh on my bare arms.
I put my chin up,
my shoulders back,
and walked to the end
of the line, where
other patrons waited to get in.
Frightened, but
aware, I continued
to look around and
behind me for any sign
that someone had
recognized me as a soldier.
I thought back to
the decal in my car
that was used for
entry into Fort Carson.
Did anybody see me
get out of the car?
Would anyone here be able
to recognize the decal
and turn me in?
I tried not to let the
thoughts get the better of me.
I did my best to hide my
anxiety while I waited in line.
I decided that I wouldn't
look back to the car
so that even if someone
recognized the decal,
they wouldn't be
able to see that I
was the one who owned the car.
I studied the guys in
line in front of me.
They were young, thin,
and overwhelmingly white.
My presence commanded
attention from some of them.
I was greeted by a
dismissive look up and down
and a shoulder turned
back to the front.
I looked at my
watch, and noticed
that it was 2:00 am
on the dot, finally.
After waiting in line for
what seemed like an eternity,
I noticed it began to move.
The line behind me had grown.
I was far too nervous to
look anyone in the eye,
so I glanced back, taking in
only shoulders, tight jeans,
and scuffed up shoes.
After moving through the
line, I entered the club
and into a different world.
Making my way
through the hallway,
I noticed more guys
who were around my age.
The place was filled with
the stench of old beer.
My shoes stuck to the
floor as I walked down
the narrow staircase.
I could see ancient messages
written on the wall.
Johnny G sucks cock.
Alan P takes it raw.
There was something exciting,
sleazy, and dangerous,
not only about the messages,
but about where I was.
I was scared as
hell, but secretly
thrilled to be breaking the
rules, just by being here.
As I walked deeper into the
labyrinth of the dark club,
I found myself further
away from all the
stresses that dominated
my life at the base.
Sergeant Norman's harassment,
the constant fear and worry
that someone would figure
out my sexual orientation,
and the new promise
and threat of war,
were all relegated
to a place far away
as I explored this dark and
mysterious new world of Hide
and Seek.
[APPLAUSE]
JIMMY PEARSON:
First of all, what
a great name for a gay bar.
There should be a college
course on names of gay bars.
Hide and Seek, I
really like that one.
But part of what I love
about that passage,
is that it speaks to kind
of this idea of intersecting
identities that you talked
about before, and also not just,
in terms of you as a black man,
or as a member of the Army,
or as a gay man, but even
within the gay community,
there's all these different kind
of boxes we put each other in
and stuff.
And there is this feeling I
think among a lot of people
that you come out,
and then you're
just accepted into
the gay community.
And you've got all the right
cards, you watch Queer as Folk,
and you're good to go.
And what's cool
about that passage
is that it speaks to how
that's not always the case.
I talked about the boxes we put
our selves into, twinks, bears,
whatever.
Twinks judging you in the line.
You don't want to be associated
with the bear on the dance
floor.
So I was wondering if you could
speak more about after you came
out, what your experience of
being accepted or not accepted
into the LGBT
community was like.
ROB SMITH: Well,
I'll tell you this.
You made a really good point.
And I give a lot of talks
on college campuses,
like all across the
country, and a lot of these
are younger kids, 18 to 22.
And some people are out,
some people are not out.
And I think that, like you
said, there is this idea
that, wow, you know, we're
all gay, or we're all LGBTQ,
and we're going to be
in this big community,
and there's just nothing
but love and acceptance,
and it's going to be great.
And that is just not
the case, unfortunately.
I think my experience
coming out is definitely
kind of like
relegated to Colorado
and where I was living
a time at the time.
It was not easy,
even when I came out.
And this is even post-military.
Because you come
out and you think
that you have all this
stuff in common people,
because specifically talking
about being gay, we're all gay.
And then you realize, oh,
those are the white guys,
and they don't really want
to talk to the black guys.
Or this is this group, and
you have to be in this group,
or you have to be in that group.
And I have to say
that this book,
I lived these stories
in the early 2000s.
And the more things
have changed,
the more they've kind
of stayed the same.
Case in point, we
look at the images
that we have of LGBTQ
people in the media.
And still to this day, they
tend to be primarily images
of white gay men.
And this is something
that's starting to change.
And I'm glad that
this is changing.
But even to this day, I
do an Instagram account
with my husband at
Robert and Misha.
And sometimes we
get liked, and we
get commented by a lot
of these other blogs,
that are like cutest gay
couples, or gay couples,
or whatever.
So I look at these
Instagram feeds,
and they are
completely dominated
by white gay male couples.
And this Instagram
we're talking about.
Like this is 2017 going on 2018.
And there are a lot of different
things in the community that
can divide us, from race,
to socioeconomic status,
to all those different things.
And I've definitely experienced
my fair share of racism
in the LGBTQ community.
I've experienced my
fair share of classism.
These are things that
are definitely happening
and definitely still going on.
But the good thing about now,
where we're sitting right here
and talking about
this in 2017, is
I think that we are now starting
to talk about these things
more.
And when you speak about them
more, and you speak to them,
I think that it allows
us, and it gives us
the tools to try to change
some of these things.
So if I say on Twitter, or
I write an article about why
are so many heads of
LGBTQ organizations
white people will
talk about that.
And people say why is this.
And when transgender women
and men speak up and say,
we need to be represented, and
why are all these trans women
white and then we have
people like Laverne Cox
and Janet Mock come out,
and then kind of like change
that conversation around what
the face of transgender is.
And I think that for me,
in writing this book,
and making the very
specific choice
to put my image on the
cover, is saying that this is
a book about a black gay man.
And I'm going to put
my face on the cover.
Because back in
the day, when I was
talking to publishers
and things about that,
one thing about the
publishing industry
is that you will be told
in not uncertain terms
that sometimes putting a
black face on the cover
is not going to sell.
JIMMY PEARSON: Really?
ROB SMITH: Yeah, absolutely.
And even doing things
that are LGBT oriented,
putting a black face on the
cover is not going to sell.
So it was very important
for me to represent myself
and other black
gay men, I think,
by putting myself on the cover.
JIMMY PEARSON: We
should see if we
can prove them wrong by
buying a lot of gay books
with a black person
on the cover.
ROB SMITH: Absolutely.
But there should be more.
And a point to that is
that, still to this day,
we are going on, what, 15
years after the war in Iraq.
This is still one of, I
believe less than five books
that have been written by
African-American soldiers
of any sexual
orientation or gender
identity about their
experiences in Iraq.
So in writing this book,
and in doing this--
and I like to bill it as
"Moonlight" meets American--
"Moonlight" meets
"American Sniper."
So the question is why, when
we look at these books that
are about the military,
when we watch these movies,
when we watch these
miniseries, why are they always
about straight white
men, when the military is
one of the most
diverse organizations
you'll ever work in your life,
you know, I've ever worked in.
It's still the only place
in my entire career,
and I've done a lot of things,
where I've had a black boss.
It's still the only place
I've ever had a black boss.
So I really wanted to make
sure that that was represented.
JIMMY PEARSON: It's
interesting when
you talk about how you lived
these in the early 2000s,
and now it's 2017, and
things have changed,
but there's still the same.
ROB SMITH: Yeah.
JIMMY PEARSON: I'm a little
embarrassed to admit this,
one of the first things
that came to my mind
was "Will and Grace."
ROB SMITH: Yeah.
JIMMY PEARSON: It was
popular back then,
and it's now back, God help us.
And it's always been
kind of controversial,
specifically because it paints
a very specific white, affluent,
urban picture of what
gay life is like.
ROB SMITH: It does, and I think
the reason why is because--
and this speaks to having people
of color that are actually
writing, and having people
creating.
Because the first thing,
when-- the first bit of advice
that people give you
as a writer, is they
say write what you know.
And if we have a
lot of people that
are in positions of power
that are even putting out
gay or LGBTQ content,
that are white guys,
the first thing they're going
to write is what they know.
What they know is upper
middle class, white gay guys,
living in large cities.
And that's great, because God
knows, there's a lot of them.
But there's also a lot of
different people having
a lot of different experiences.
And the most exciting
thing now is--
I'm having a meeting with some
agents in a couple of weeks,
because I'm really
trying to push
like getting this adapter
for the big screen,
or Netflix, or
something like that.
I think that the most
exciting thing right now
is that there's so many
platforms out there.
So not only do we have
the Legacy Networks,
but we have the Hulu's and the
Netflix's and the Facebook's,
and all that stuff.
And there's so much
more opportunity
to get different
stories that represent
marginalized
communities out there.
And if you have a
movie like "Moonlight,"
that just won an Academy
Award for Best Picture, that
means that somewhere out
there, somewhere, there
are people that are open and
receptive to these stories.
And I think that now
is the time for that.
Even though the new "Will and
Grace" is still pretty funny.
JIMMY PEARSON: Is it?
ROB SMITH: It's OK.
JIMMY PEARSON: I wasn't
a fan of the original.
I gave myself away earlier.
I wasn't really a
fan of the original.
Well, that's cool.
ROB SMITH: Yeah.
JIMMY PEARSON: And
one other question I
have about this
idea of acceptance
in the LGBT community is,
what about as a veteran
specifically, do you feel that
you are viewed differently,
for better or worse, as a
veteran in the gay community?
Or does it not come up at all?
ROB SMITH: It doesn't come
up in the gay community.
I can talk to being a veteran
in the overall community.
JIMMY PEARSON: Sure.
ROB SMITH: And what I'll
say about being a veteran,
just in the
community in general,
is that people don't
understand, people
don't understand
being a veteran.
People don't respect
People think military
service is strange and odd.
These are things
that I've dealt with
and a lot of different workplace
situations I've been in.
When you have an all-volunteer
military that adds up to,
I think maybe 1% to 3%
of America's population,
and this is specifically
talking about America,
then chances are that the
vast majority of people
don't know anybody
who served, have never
met anybody who served, don't
have anybody in their family
who served.
So they have no idea.
And so the idea is
that these are just--
poor people are just
cannon fodder for America.
And that's some of the
feedback that I've gotten.
And this is stuff that
comes from wealthy liberals
on the coasts.
And these are some of the ideas
that people carry with them,
before they find out
that I'm a veteran.
And then I make things
very awkward for them
when they bring this stuff up.
And then people
talk about things
like the military industrial
complex and all that.
And those are valid arguments.
Those are valid
things to talk about.
And even in the
LGBTQ community, I
think that speaking
about veterans issues
and speaking positively
of the military
is seen as somehow conservative
or right leaning, which
I've never understood.
But I've gotten that feedback
within our community as well.
And I've never quite understood
that, because for me,
the military was the way to
expand my life and my borders
beyond the small town
that I was raised in Ohio,
the small city of Akron, Ohio.
So I think that we have
a lot of work to do,
both as an LGBTQ community,
and as a mainstream American
community in general.
We have a lot of work
to do when it comes
to understanding veterans.
And also, people that
are in hiring positions
in organizations, instead of
the first thing that you think
about when you talk to
a veteran is about PTSD,
or how horrible war must
be, or anything like that,
think about what
this person may be
able to bring to this
organization, what
are the qualities that
the military instills
in people that could help
in your organization.
I will tell you that
for me personally,
it just gave me a higher
level of discipline
than a lot of people
that I work with in a lot
of different situations.
JIMMY PEARSON: It's
interesting, you
brought up a really
good point that I
think is a little under
appreciated, which
is not only is the
all-volunteer force so small,
just numbers, say, a
few people are going
to have interactions with it.
But it's also disproportionately
southern, lower
on the economic ladder.
ROB SMITH: Lower middle
class, absolutely.
JIMMY PEARSON: Yeah,
and so, a lot of these--
I think you used the term
wealthy coastal liberal
or something like that--
are especially removed
from it, in a way.
ROB SMITH: Very much
removed from it.
JIMMY PEARSON: So
in the interest
of spreading a little
bit more about what
the experience of being
in Iraq is actually like--
ROB SMITH: Yes.
JIMMY PEARSON:
That's a good a segue
as any into the last passage
that you're going to read.
ROB SMITH: It is.
And I will keep this
brief, because I
know we wanted to open
it up for questions.
So this is-- here we go.
And this is very short.
So this is basically, I served
for slightly under a year right
after the initial invasion.
My-- actually my entire
company convoyed into Iraq.
So we drove from
Kuwait into Iraq.
And we kind of made little
pit stops along the way.
And this is describing that.
When we crossed the border into
Iraq just a few hours later,
I noticed an immediate
difference in the scenery.
The streets of Iraq had a
look of war-strewn desperation
to them that was
hard to stomach.
Everywhere I looked
I saw Arabic language
that I couldn't understand.
The roadsides were littered
with abandoned fighter vehicles
that the Saddam loyalists had
used in their futile attempts
to defend themselves against
the American invaders.
Small, brown Iraqi children
would come out of nowhere
sometimes, running and
waving with the tanks.
We were moving slow
enough in the 15 to 20
vehicle convoy for them to
keep up with to a point.
They wore tattered pants and
t-shirts with logos and brands
from them that were
distinctly from the '80s.
Their high voices were
filled with joy and hope
as they chanted, "America, USA,"
with bright smiles and hands
extended in the
thumbs up position.
Many times they were
alone, but sometimes older,
hardened Iraqi men, who
looked at us with contempt
and distrust joined them.
I smiled and waved
at the children.
They were ignorant of the
fact that I was doing so
with a semi-automatic
weapon positioned directly
in front of me.
When I saw the faces
of the adult men,
I gripped my weapon just
a little bit tighter.
I pressed the
button of my weapon
deeper into my shoulder in
case any unforeseen events
required me to have it
in position immediately.
I would look each
man in his eyes
above the heads of the
small, simple children
they were protecting.
I matched the
contempt in their eyes
with steely resolve in mine.
They needed to know
that I wouldn't
hesitate to pull
the trigger in case
they wanted to try anything.
I found myself locking
eyes with most of them
until we were
safely out of view.
I wondered what
they thought of us,
American infidels who had
come to violently overthrow
the regime.
I saw a lot of children and
a lot of angry Iraqi men
during those days on the convoy.
I thought a lot about
how I would feel
if the situation was reversed.
What if my country had
been bombed into submission
for reasons that
were still murky?
What was it about America that
determined that we were always
right in using force?
If we were to listen
to what was told
to us by the government
and our leaders,
Saddam Hussein was a
bloodthirsty tyrant.
He was to unleash weapons
of mass destruction
onto an unsuspecting
American public.
I just couldn't allow
myself to be convinced.
Were the 9/11 attackers
not based in Afghanistan?
The shift from talking about
Afghanistan to focusing on Iraq
was so swift and
smooth, I didn't even
realize it happened.
All I knew was that after
returning from the first six
month deployment in Kuwait,
all talk had suddenly
shifted to Iraq.
I wanted to trust what
was being told to us,
but the questions
in my head wouldn't
allow me to do so fully.
Was blind trust a prerequisite
to serving the country,
or does it just make it
easier to do the job?
JIMMY PEARSON: So I'll just ask
you one question about this,
because I do want to open it up
for audience questions as well.
ROB SMITH: Sure.
JIMMY PEARSON: I
think what you see
here is your point
that you made earlier
about empathy kind of
made explicit, right?
ROB SMITH: Yes.
JIMMY PEARSON: As
you imagine what
it's like to be those
children or those angry men.
And it's related to this
question of the doubt
that you felt, and
whether that doubt was
an impediment to you serving.
So I guess that's
my question for you
is, if you could say more
about whether you did feel that
to some extent that empathy
was a blocker for you
and something that made
this much more difficult.
ROB SMITH: It was.
Like I said in that
segment, or in that reading,
there was a lot of
misinformation that
was going on around that time.
I mean, now we can
look back on it,
and we can say we know
what it was about.
And it wasn't necessarily
about the fear
that Saddam Hussein had WMDs.
And there was a lot of
doubt, a lot of fear,
a lot of conversations going on
between me and other soldiers.
And I get into that a
little bit in the book.
There's a lot of talk about
exactly why are we here.
There's a lot of rumors about
Saddam's going to be over,
and they're going to
love us, and we're just
going to be out of here
in a couple of months.
And that didn't happen.
JIMMY PEARSON: Right.
ROB SMITH: It's quite
obvious that didn't happen.
But I do think that being
an other in the military,
being a black person
in the military--
and I deal with some of the
racial issues more explicitly
earlier on when I talk
about basic training.
Because when I was in basic
training in the south,
I was the only black person
in the entire company.
But I think that
when you're there,
and you're dealing with a lot
of-- let me tell you something,
you're dealing with a
lot of good old boys.
And you're dealing, in
a lot of situations,
where sometimes you are one of
the only black people around.
And you will kind of
understand and get
a kind of an inside view
of how people treat others.
I talk a little bit
about in the book
about how they used to call
the Iraq people like haji.
You know, haji but better
not mess up, or haji better
not do this, because
we'll put a bullet in him,
all that other stuff.
And just as a black person,
as a black man, I just--
some of the conversations
and some of the behaviors
just felt to me
intrinsically wrong.
And I get into
that a little bit.
But I do feel like I had more
empathy going in that situation
just as a person of color.
And I will identify
myself as a person
of color in that instance.
Because that's something
that I shared in common
with them, the Iraqi people.
Like we are both
people of color.
And when you look
at the military,
it was these overwhelmingly
white male forces
that were coming in to kind
of dominate that situation.
So I think that it did help me
look at it through a lens that
was a lot different,
which brings it
back to why I thought it was
so important to put this out.
Because the lens of--
taking the gay out of it--
the lens of the military,
a view of the military
through the lens of
a black man, is not
something that exists enough.
JIMMY PEARSON: Yeah.
All right, I have a ton
of follow-up questions,
and stuff about my own
personal experience
that we'll talk
about afterwards.
But I do want to make
sure that everyone
has time to ask questions,
and we're at a quarter till.
So reminder, if you
do have questions,
please line up behind the
mics, and we'll open it up.
I think you're the
only one right now.
AUDIENCE: Right to the front?
ROB SMITH: Yes.
I'm so glad somebody
had a question,
because it's so awkward
when people don't.
It's the worst.
AUDIENCE: So my question
comes out of the first reading
that you had from your book,
when you talked about coming
out to your mother.
And you mentioned
to her quoting how
it wasn't part of God's plan.
And I often hear about
people using religion
as a stick to beat back what's
uncomfortable or strange
to them.
And I'm wondering,
it sounds like you
come from a household that
had a good deal of faith,
or at least, that was
part of the culture.
And I was wondering if you could
talk about your experiences
coming out to those with
kind of a faith upbringing
and in that community.
And then, on top of
that, if you, yourself,
have found a faith group that
is accepting to you since.
ROB SMITH: Yeah,
that's interesting.
I did I grew up in a Christian
household, African Methodist
Episcopal to be specific.
And I know a lot of people,
particularly black gay men,
who were born and
raised in the church,
and who were born and raised
in homophobic churches.
And when you internalize
those messages
when you're very young, they can
be very, very hard to overcome.
And I've spoken to people
that have had that experience
in their churches.
For me, I didn't
have that experience
in my church growing up.
I never heard
anything either way
about anything gay in my church.
It was just never about that.
And so I feel like I'm able to
have a relationship with God
right now, but it doesn't
have that baggage on it, where
I had to come back and realize
that oh, all of these things
that were being told
to me about being gay,
or homosexuality, or
whatever were wrong,
and they were a perversion
of what the Bible is saying
and all that stuff.
To be more specific about a
faith community that I found,
I'm more spiritual than overtly
religious at this point.
There were-- I
mean, at my wedding,
I have a friend that's a choir
master at a church on the Upper
East Side.
He semi-officiated my ceremony.
We jumped the broom.
And everybody who's-- everybody
knows the slave tradition
of jumping the broom
and all that stuff.
They jumped the
broom because they
weren't unable to be married.
And so I did that at my wedding.
And I have a kind
of mentor that is
a black gay pastor at an
affirming church on the Upper
West Side.
So that's what my relationship
is to faith and Christianity
right now.
And I know that some people
in the community hate it.
They hate anything that
has to do with faith,
because there are so many
people who use faith, and who
use Christianity, and
who use these things,
and they pervert those
messages in order
to ostracize people
that are gay,
and people in the
LGBTQ community.
And I understand why people
are so hesitant to embrace it.
I've never really
had that experience.
And my mother brought that up.
And by the way, we're
on very good terms now.
These things
happened a while ago.
So we were able to kind
of come back around.
And I say, look,
parents are people too.
And coming out isn't always
an after-school special.
Mine certainly wasn't.
But she was going through
a lot at the time.
She got cancer twice.
And she was at a
point in her life
where she was very
religious, and that's
where that was coming from.
So I would say that my
relationship with Christianity
right now is fairly strong.
JIMMY PEARSON: Thank
you for the question.
ROB SMITH: Sure.
Who was first?
AUDIENCE: I don't know.
ROB SMITH: OK.
JIMMY PEARSON: Why
don't you go ahead.
We'll split mic to mic.
AUDIENCE: Thank you so
much for coming here,
and I really appreciate
you speaking out
about your experiences.
My question is about the
people you served with.
Do you have an
ongoing relationship
with a lot of the
people that you
served with when
you weren't out,
and did you have to come out
to them, and how did that go?
ROB SMITH: Yeah, well I will
say Facebook is a powerful tool.
That might get edited out.
No, Facebook is a
really powerful tool
to just connect with people.
And I'm friends with,
I'm Facebook friends
with people that I served.
And we're in open dialogue.
As a matter of fact, somebody
just commented on a post
that I made about
this the other day.
And he asked me if
he was in the book.
And I said, yeah,
you're right there.
Of course, your name has been
changed, because I changed
everybody else's name but mine.
So I do still have those
relationships with them.
And the reactions
when I came out,
and I got into a lot of heavy
activist work when Don't Ask,
Don't Tell was still
the law of the land.
I was arrested at the White
House protesting Don't Ask,
Don't Tell.
And then when a lot of
that stuff was happening,
they would kind of hit me up
via social media and all that.
And it ranged from we kind
of figured you were gay,
but nobody really cared to--
oh, this is a big surprise.
But you know what, it doesn't
make a difference to me,
because, you know,
you were still Smitty,
you know, you're still
Smitty, you're still
a soldier, stuff like that.
So I do have those
relationships still to this day.
And I guess the
worst part about it
is that I know that
those relationships could
have been stronger.
But it was just, with that law,
it just wasn't good timing.
AUDIENCE: Thank you.
ROB SMITH: Sure.
And you had one?
AUDIENCE: Yes, hello.
ROB SMITH: Hi.
AUDIENCE: Hi, my
name is Kelsy, I just
wanted to thank you so
much for being here,
and for serving our country,
and for sharing your story.
You kind of stole
my question, so I'm
going to tweak mine a
little bit, if that's OK.
So you spoke about how it was
really hard for you to come out
to you mom, and you
couldn't, obviously, come out
when you were in the military.
So who did you confide
in during that time,
and how did you cope with the
mental health aspect of it?
Because I know, when
you're hiding who you are,
sometimes it brings
depression or anxiety.
So how did you cope with that
and who did you confide in?
ROB SMITH: You know, right
after the first reading
I did, I talk about the night
that I almost ended my life.
And I talked to my sister, who
was and remains my best friend,
and she kind of talked
me off the ledge.
So when I was in the military,
I confided with her a lot.
There are people that I
came out to on the sly
when I was in the military.
But to tell you the truth,
at that point in my life,
it was a very kind
of lonely road.
And I'm really glad that she
brought up the conversation
about mental health.
I speak out about
an organization
called the Soldiers Project.
If nobody knows what
the Soldiers Project is,
it is an organization-- you
go to soldiersproject.org,
and if you are a veteran,
or even active duty,
I believe, in the
armed forces, they
have a network of
therapists and psychiatrists
that work for free.
And they will connect you
to somebody in your area
within 24 to 48 hours.
I didn't really
start taking control
of my mental health
and dealing with what
I needed to do in that realm
until about maybe five,
six years ago.
And I found my therapist
through the Soldiers Project.
And it has been an
immense help for me
to work through some of the
stuff that is in this book.
And also, some of
the mental health
stuff that just comes with being
a gay person in this society.
You are just not like
87% of other people.
And I think that
we kid ourselves
when we ignore the mental stress
that comes along with that.
So that was the way--
to answer your question,
I wasn't able to start taking
care of my mental health
until about six or
seven years ago.
Because it was
really time to start
dealing with some of the issues
that this work brings up.
AUDIENCE: Thank you.
ROB SMITH: Thank you.
Thanks for giving
me an opportunity
to mention the Soldiers Project.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE].
ROB SMITH: Yeah, absolutely.
JIMMY PEARSON: Yeah, definitely.
ROB SMITH: They give me nothing
but free mental health care,
by the way.
AUDIENCE: Thank you
so much for coming.
Fascinating story.
And thank you for your service.
One of the things--
you're intersecting in so many
interesting ways, soldier,
veteran, gay, black.
And I know in my experience
as a gay white man,
I don't have to--
well, another aspect
of my identity
is that I'm a Christian, which
I don't reveal much here.
ROB SMITH: OK.
AUDIENCE: So I'm wondering
are the other aspects
of your identity that you
found easier to expose.
Like in your workplace, is
it easier to be a veteran
or easier to be gay?
ROB SMITH: I'll
tell you, you want
you to be completely
honest, in any workplace,
it's not easy to
be anything that's
not heterosexual and white.
Let's just keep it
all the way real.
When I think about identities
and which one is easier to be,
I mean, I would
think that for me--
that's a tough one,
because to me, it's
not about what's
easier, it's not
about what identity is
easier to be for me,
it's about fully inhabiting
all of my identities.
And I feel like
I've done the work
to get to this point, where
I'm comfortable enough
with who I am that what other
people think of me, based
on these things, don't matter.
[APPLAUSE]
So I can't take on--
oh, my god, you know,
is everybody going
to think that I'm
less capable because I'm black.
Or are they going to
think that I shouldn't
be on camera because I'm gay.
Or are they going to think I'm
crazy, because I'm a veteran.
You know, I physically
can't take those things on.
So I have to own all of
these identities in any space
that I enter into.
And this is-- I mean, look, I'm
dealing in finance right now,
where I am dealing with--
the majority of people
that I deal with
are white and straight.
And if I kind of
carry that baggage
from my identities
on my back, it
would really hinder my
ability to do my job
and to be effective in my job.
I hope that answers
the question.
So to completely
answer the question,
there is no one thing
that's easier than the other
to deal with.
I will tell you that as a
black man in society, that is
the identity that people see.
That is how I am treated.
People don't know gay, and
they don't know veteran,
but they know black.
And that is how I'm
treated more so.
So that is that kind
of discrimination
that is more overt to me
in my life than anything
based on religion or sexuality.
AUDIENCE: Hey.
JIMMY PEARSON: Hey.
AUDIENCE: So you talked a
bit about misconceptions
in the broader
population about what
it means to be in the military,
or just lack of knowledge.
And I was wondering what
you thought or believed
about the military before
you decided to enlist
and where those ideas came from.
ROB SMITH: I was
very young, I was 17.
Yeah, obviously,
five years ago-- no.
So I was I 17, I was very young.
And my ideas about
the military were--
so, one of the things that--
this is a story that you're not
going to get from
a straight book,
is about how I was
completely obsessed
with my military recruiter.
He was just gorgeous.
Oh, my god.
I mean he--
JIMMY PEARSON: They pick
them for that reason.
ROB SMITH: They do, I
mean, they really do.
And this is-- there's some
embarrassing stuff in there
about how my heart just went
pitter-patter when he came by.
But he was filling
my head with a lot
of stories about how
it'd be just like camping
and all that other stuff.
So I was getting this
idea, well, the infantry,
that will be cool.
And you know, I'll get to sleep
out, and I'll get to camp,
and I'll get to
do all this stuff.
Mind you, 17 years old.
That was not the case.
So those ideas of the military
did not come to fruition.
It was definitely
not summer camp.
It was no fairy tale
or anything like that.
But like I said before, I think
that the experiences that I've
had just made me stronger.
It made me kind of unbreakable.
And I wouldn't wish
some of the stuff
that I went through on anybody.
But I do believe that right now,
when we have things like-- when
Don't Ask, Don't Tell is over,
and the military is trying
to come, I guess, into 2017.
Slowly, but surely,
they'll be here,
even though there's still
some issues with transgender
soldiers that we're still
trying to work out nowadays.
And nobody knows what's
going on with that.
But I do think that there are
a lot of positive qualities
that the military has.
There's a lot of
positive qualities
that it can instill
in a lot of people.
And I'd never want
to bash the military.
I only bash discrimination,
discriminatory policies,
and discriminatory people.
AUDIENCE: I feel really bad,
because I know you're waiting,
but I think that has to be our
last question, because we're
about out of time.
I really am sorry.
But Rob is going to hang
out for a while afterwards.
ROB SMITH: I'll be here.
I'll hang out, so we'll talk.
JIMMY PEARSON: And I did want
to have one last opportunity
to say thank you to Rob.
A, for joining us, but B, on a
personal note, as a sailor who
served both before and after
Don't Ask, Don't Tell repeal,
for your activism, and helping
to get that policy repealed,
and everything.
ROB SMITH: Absolutely.
Thank you for your service.
JIMMY PEARSON: Thank you.
Thank you again to
Rob, and thank you
to everyone for coming
and for your questions.